ce
profil sans pouvoir être
extrêmement détaillé et ne faire qu'un
seul profil mais nous est apparu
néanmoins comme sur le plan
sociod-démographique relativement
homogène et je vais me risquer à vous
donner ce ce ce profil tel qu'il est et
tel qu'il nous apparaît à savoir un
homme de nationalité française je
préciserai les pour
moyenne d'âge 23 ans célibataire sans
enfant hébergé souvent par ses
parents ayant un diplôme de niveau
secondaire maximum
bacalaoréa plutôt en activité
et voilà pour le profil
socio-démographique des petits points de
précision j'ai dit de nationalités donc
des hommes 91 % d'hommes de nationalité
française 71 % sont de nationalité
française 75 sont nés en
France les statistiques que nous avons
ne répertorient que la nationalité et le
lieu de naissance donc nous ne pouvons
donner que des éléments à la fois sur la
nationalité sur le lieu de naissance
euh sur donc 87 % de célibataires pas
d'enfants pas d'enfant à charge euh 61 %
ont un emploi une activité
professionnelle suivent une formation
donc en fait 39 % se déclare chômeur ou
sans
activité voilà pour le profil euh
socio-démographique nous avons ensuite
révéler un profil judiciaire que nous
avons qualifié de plus contrasté parce
que nous avons bien conscience de la
façon dont les choses peuvent être
envisagées euh puisque 57 % de ces
auteurs condamnés définitif au 31 au 31
juillet 57 % sont sans antécédents
judiciaaires évidemment 43 ont des
antécédents
judiciaaires donc euh voilà le la sign
pourquoi nous avons choisi ce
qualificatif de contraster
euh puisque la majorité pas si
significative que ça euh dans ceux qui
sont euh déjà euh condamnés mais bien
sûr les condamnations au vu de leur
jeune âge he puisque je vous ai dit 23
ans de moyenne date ou remonte à 1 an ou
à 18 mois auparavant et dans les
personnes condamnées 10 des 10 % des
condamnation étit prononcé avec la
mention de la récidive légale donc ils
étaient en état de récidive légale au
sens juridique ça ne veut pas dire de la
réitération peut-être certains étaient
en réitération c'est-à-dire recommencer
des faits mais la récidive légale c'est
une notion juridique euh de de même
infraction ou d'infraction similaire
donc 10 % était en état euh de récidive
légale